[Music]
Ariana Grande and SNL star listen when
you know you know that's what they say
yeah okay that's what I guess so but if
you saw heat on The Tonight Show last
night which is his first interview since
the engagement well you could tell even
he was having a hard time believing it
you feel like I want a contest in route
to Fallon last night Pete and Ariana
enjoyed some lollipops outside their new
16 million dollar 4,000 square-foot love
nest in New York a source confirmed to
ET the 24 year olds are living together
and are excited for the next chapter
some do girls Muse like yo man you like
gave me hope
the singer only went public with the SNL
comedian twenty two days before getting
engaged with a 93 thousand dollar rock
beats taking his mr. Ariana Grande
status in stride forever like known as
I'm excited yeah him whatever yeah going
on while Pete's SNL co-star Heidi
Gardner promoting season three of her
animated super ancient series played coy
about Davidson's relationship to ET he
and Ariana aren't the first romance
inside third rock this fling that I had
with a guy on this show back then Emma
Stone joked about it but a source
confirmed to ET she did start casually
dating two shows writer director Dave
McGarry last year we're told they're
still together also going strong
Scarlett Johansson and Weekend Update
host Colin Jost a couple for over a year
now they fit up several red carpet
meanwhile Ben Affleck and SNL producer
Lindsay shook us are also uncool display
the pair of one-year was seen having
dinner this week in LA the source tells
et they're very much in love but Ben
isn't ready to propose what's in the
water at SNL all I've seen in the water
is women I guess that's good
[Music]